Now, uh, uh, also I would like
to spend a couple of minutes, uh,
kind of wrapping up some,
uh, issues, uh, about, uh,
the four orders of what we
covered in that test, right? Uh,
Mark Snitcher Fried and labor.
Um,
uh,
just to help you to get that overall sense
right for the bottom line is and what
the similarities and differences are.
And then I go into Max Faber.
There is a lot dive on to cover today.
Would love to talk a lot about his life.
I won't have time.
Uh,
I could give you a lot of my
stem juicy stories, what I have,
but I, I unfortunately I,
I have to be told myself.
Ah, okay. So the four alters, um,
that is one important common
feature in all four quarters.
And some of these things from
the theorist we studied so far,
uh,
in one way or another or four of
them can be called critical theorist.
That means they are offer critical
analysis of what is in your mind.
They say what is in your mind is not
necessarily what you think it is.
Less subjects,
your consciousness to critical scrutiny.
I think all four do share these argument,
right? Um, mark,
certainly even the idea that,
well,
the dominant ideas of each ebook
are the ideas of the dominant class.
Um, and therefore you think what
is in your mind is your idea.
They tell me what your class position is
and diabetes tell you value your ideas
are coming from right. Uh, now, uh,
uh, uh, this is an hs project
and he said, well, you sing,
this is mortality.
I will show the immorality of morality.
What you think is more, right. Uh,
this is certainly fried you thing.
This is your ideas.
Well,
they all my couch and I
talked to me and I will,
you have,
you'll recall all these early sexual
experiences in your life and then you will
realize, uh, what, who
you really are. Well,
you know, um, vapor is a little
more complicated, but uh,
he also has this idea of legitimacy
and domination with some later Marxists
speak on this.
And the fundamental idea of vapor is
coming also from nature in the fundamental
idea is that we actually do internalize
the very principles of our submission.
That's what legitimacy,
at least in my interpretation
in Vba is that his domination,
right? And therefore vapor is
also helps you to understand,
right where these ideas are coming from
and to what extent you yourself are you
own jail keeper,
right?
As sort of mine a little
postmodernist reading of Max Faber.
Um,
so these are this in this way they are
or critical theory stride the architects,
the architects of consciousness,
but there are fundamental
differences between the four authors.
Um, and in some ways, uh,
there is a similarity between marks
and fried Marx and Freud all thick.
They're point of departure
in their project to be
critical of consciousness for
sensors, human experience, right?
Material or reality in one way or another.
They are both materialists, right? Um,
of course four marks.
It is reductionist because the sensors,
human experience is
reduced to the economy.
Uh,
you tell me about your position
in the economic system are then,
I understand when you have
economic interests, Trad,
you are behaving and you are thinking
according to your economic interest and
then ivy law, understand what is
on your mind. Now, by the way,
it's not all that different,
right?
From Adam Smith's and rationally actor,
rationally acting individuals.
Maurice has some similarities.
All the offers it critically by
Adam Smith's Fr the affirmatively.
But that is Mark's reductionism,
that what is sensors like?
Experience is reduced to the economy.
And then he also has an
agency that's the big, uh,
uh,
unique feature of Marx theory.
He knows what will society is,
does not describe in much detail,
but has an idea about good society.
And he knows who the historical agent is,
will be lead us there.
I mean,
many of you were probably turned
off by his vision of the future,
but the strengths of the theories that
he has a vision of good society and he
knows how to get there.
So those of you who are
looking for answers,
Karl Marx does have answers for you right
now. Uh, uh, uh,
what about, uh, uh, uh, uh, fried?
He does not quite have
answers to you, right? Man,
you want to on his couch, right? Uh,
he helps you to discover the rep fest,
these jars in yourself,
and then it will help you to
get rid of your depression,
anxieties, hysteria or whatever
you are suffering from.
Right. But it, there'll
be up to you right,
to somehow figuring out what is for the
oppressed and we only will help you to
find it.
Right.
And does he have a very
clearly defined good society?
He has sort of ambiguous
attitudes about this, right?
A CV [inaudible] modern civilization.
Well this is coming from repression.
CBLI physician has a lot to do,
how people are being controlled.
On the other hand,
he knows out of the Ed,
a lot of nasty,
aggressive stuff is coming from
and they have to be wrapped breast.
So he has a kind of ambiguous,
our attitude.
He does not want to go
against civilization,
but he sees the dark side of
civilization at the same time.
Now what these common uh, in, uh, um, uh,
nature and vapor that they
all depart from this idea,
right? Uh, that it is sensors,
experiences from which you
have to understand, right?
What's wrong with your consciousness?
There.
Central concern is power,
right?
Power and domination.
It is not the economy,
it is not sexuality.
It is power.
And interestingly,
in some ways,
therefore they've probably
reach back all the way to hops,
right?
That all history of human candy
struggle around Bowel Hour.
Now this is the most radical he done
by nature because what Nicha is doing
right?
He shows you how the most to noble ideas,
but you have in your mind
are actually manufacturer,
right in the workshop of ideals,
in very mass.
You Vase by course shern right?
Uh,
by torture and he shows you
this instrument of growers.
Um, uh, if the, he's
sturdy of, uh, uh, the,
the Museum of Historical Museum of
Marx is filled up with the means of
production.
You go into a museum,
you can see the life,
right? How people lived,
what that house was, but the instruments
where they produce their livelihood.
You'll see this, a lot of contemporary
museums, which are not Marxists,
but still inspired by these
Marxian idea niches museum there.
Well, you'll feel fine.
Guillotines right? Be,
you'll find all these
instrument of torture.
That's human history. The
history of torture. And that's,
that is an interesting similarity
between a Viber and nature,
namely, that the history
of humankind is evolution.
But this evolution has its downside.
Our bodies may not be tortured
any longer in modern civilization,
but our souls are kept hostage.
That's the bad news right now. Uh,
uh,
I think that's in a nutshell,
I think the kind of similarities and
differences of the four [inaudible] we
covered for these tests.
And I don't think I have
more time to deal with this.
So let's now go to Max Faber.
Um,
and I am actually very sensitive.
Somebody asked a question, a veteran, um,
uh, the, uh, uh, on, on, on the
desk, the question on domination,
should it be the Ivr be thinking
very hard about this. In fact,
if you still have a very
much disliked questions,
send me an email and by will try to
take this into consideration. Okay.
So this is Max Faber,
uh,
born in 1864 and died in a 19 or 20.
Um, uh, well nowadays with flu shots,
he would not have died.
He just died of pneumonia.
It probably would have lived longer.
Fortunately,
he did not because he
did not leave Nazi-ism.
And we do not have to ask
the unpleasant question.
Worth have Max Faber
third into BMFC I doubt,
but there are some who
believe he might have.
And vivio we'll talk
about this later at all.
So a word about the Max Faber family.
Uh,
this is a Protestant family who
live in the city of Sal's work,
be, it was, which was
in the Habsburg Empire.
It was actually an independent city,
uh,
ruled by an archbishop,
very Catholic city.
And by the late 18th century,
these arch bishop started to take, uh, uh,
counter that for Nisha to seriously.
So therefore,
those who were not Roman Catholic
better left suited the vapor family.
And they moved to Germany in the Rhineland
and they settled in Bielefeld and
they set up a textile
manufacturing business,
which operated pretty good.
Uh,
Weber's fodder.
Max Senior was the younger of two songs
and the family business though it was
doing okay. It was not enough to
support two families. Therefore,
he was asked to, uh, uh,
learn some trade. So he, uh,
uh,
actually entered CVL service and
became a politician and Seville server.
Um, uh, Max Faber himself was
born in 64 in air force, uh,
um,
in the eastern part of Germany where
his father was stationed at that time.
And, uh, his mother of us, Helen
enough Steen, a very sensitive,
wonderful woman.
There were eight brothers and sisters,
a big family and quite a
family. Uh, here you have a,
the three brothers, um, uh,
Max on the left and the middle,
afraid vapor,
afraid vapor was quite a scholar.
He was a younger brother of Max and
he was a very prominent economist,
philosopher and sociologist,
Bri,
primarily economist who was val northern
for the theory of industrial location
in his times. He was a professor
that University of Heidelberg.
He did not turn into a Nazi.
He was actually laid off by the Nazis
and there is a statute in eight,
1945.
Those of you who study in economics,
industrial relation theory may have
comment close the name of Alfred Vapor.
He was actually the femurs vapor.
Max Faber was less famous
in his Stein then Alfred.
Uh, now Max Weber's mother
was Halena, as I said,
she was a wonderful lady and,
uh,
she was a devil with Calvinists.
So now you can understand the role of
Calvinism in the Protestant ethic in the
waiver, um, and, uh, uh,
was also greatly
interested in philanthropy.
And that's where Weber's social
sensitivity is coming from.
Uh,
there was a great deal of conflict
between the sensitive Helena and,
uh,
Max's senior who was a very auditory
Italian paternalistic figure.
It a very unpleasant guy,
political yours,
so extremely conservative. And
they had quite a bit of, uh,
uh, uh, conflict 50
charter early in his life.
Max sided with his father did devote
fried sad you will do when you would
overcome your early posts complex
to identify you with your father.
Okay,
this is what he did.
But then he actually shifted
and eventually started with,
with his murderer. Well,
this is the father. Well,
I would not have liked him as my father.
Um, uh, um, uh,
he was a conservative politician,
uh, a very patriarchal figure,
a very,
he watched,
started in the municipality
as a cvs servant in air foot.
Then became actually a deputy
of the National Liberal Party,
which had very little to do with
liberalism. It was a conservative party.
Um, uh, um,
uh, this was under the
chancellorship of auto phone,
the Bismarck at the Ireland Chancellor,
real conservative times in Germany.
MMM.
Now, uh, about Weber's lives. Uh,
he studied in Heidelberg
and then in Berlin, uh,
he studied in both law
and agrarian history. Uh,
uh,
actually he was some valid between
a legal theories that historian,
um, and an economist. He was
kind of sociologists, uh,
last, uh, uh, in 92, he
married Marianna Schnittger,
who was a kind of second cousin,
Ivo come back to this
relationship. Later on, uh,
in 95, he was appointed professor
of economics at Fribourg,
and then he moved to Heidelberg that he
basically spent the rest of his life.
Um,
uh,
he also became a professor
of political science.
Um, uh, he was involved early in
his life in very feverish acronym,
uh,
academic activities.
He published two Phd dissertation,
one in law and one in
history. Uh, the law,
the law phd was on commercial
law in medieval Italy.
And, uh, the, uh,
history was on agrarian
history in the room walls,
books were published. The, um, uh,
and the are actually not in English.
Yeah.
Um, uh, uh,
liter version of,
uh,
the agrarian history was
published in [inaudible] 97.
He suffered a very serious,
a nervous breakdown.
I would love to talk in detail
about this. Uh, by all likelihood,
it had a lot to do with his
conflict with his father. Uh,
just during the summer of 97, um, uh, uh,
the modern visited,
he visited the patterns in
and then the mother said,
well, I want to visit you in
Heidelberg. And then the father said,
no, you can't because I
need you here. Right. Uh,
who via cook my breakfast.
Uh, and then Max Faber,
who was over as a subservient that
there'll be the, unto the father, Rev,
Walter Reed. And he said,
father, you can't do that.
If modern wants to visit us,
she should be allowed to visit us.
And this happened the first time that
Max Weber's said no to the father where
the father pastor of seen two or three
months and just after the death of the
father of Labor had a very
serious nervous breakdown. Now,
Novar knows exactly what it had to
do with the desks of the father,
but there is certainly a correlation
between the two facts. Uh,
it was actually a very
serious, uh, um, uh, uh,
uh, disease. Uh,
he was lucky to be married to a
Vonda food and extremely smart woman,
Marianna. Uh, they married in, uh, uh, uh,
uh,
earlier and Mariana was a great help
for him to recover from this nervous
breakdown for five years.
Bieber could not teach,
could not write good,
not read.
He will just sitting in the corner
staring he had of himself. Uh,
Mariana took him to travelers,
they went to Italy and
eventually he discovered 92.
He's coming out of his nervous
breakdown and recurrence to Heidelberg,
though he never really took on very
regular teaching youths anymore.
Now 18 or four,
he had his only trip to the
USA event to the Saint Louis.
Worth Fair and Rotor Vonda
food paper at that time.
Um, and then, uh, in 1906, uh, um,
again,
I wish I would have more time to
talk about the [inaudible] sisters.
This is a great story and the way he
obviously falls in love with Elsa Fondrick
restore fan as up on [inaudible]
was actually the wife,
uh, uh, um, uh, a good friend
and colleague of Vapor, uh,
[inaudible], uh, uh,
major, uh, political, uh,
social theories.
Well,
this is a very important event in Babers
life is slashed some dealer his desk.
It is actually not Marianna who is
standing by his desk bad about as I found
Rico Fan. Uh, interestingly Al's and
Marianna, very, very good friends. So,
uh, again, I cannot resist
to give you a little gossip,
but the best as we know,
uh,
the marriage with Mariana
was never consumed.
So these are fair with as a phone.
Rico fan is really the first real full
field Aerotek experience in Weber's life
and has a lot to do,
I think in VBS,
changing thinking about life,
um,
and modernity,
the rediscovery of the power of eroticism.
Um,
uh, then he has been doing
work, uh, on religion. Uh,
and this is mainly a response to
criticism he got for his book.
We will be trotting in a minute about
the Protestant ethic and he trusts to the
fender, uh, his very on, uh, uh, uh,
the Protestant ethic by looking at
various world religions and shows that
rationalization did not take place in
these religions as much as it happened in
Christianity. And then he's
working in his opal smuggle norm,
uh, economy. And so sadly, what
he never finished a, um, uh, uh,
died in 19 trente where all this is
Elsa from restore fund misses the Alpha.
Um, uh, uh,
she came from a very
prominent German family.
There were three very prominent and
very beautiful Rico fan sisters.
Um, uh, as I said,
Elsa was the vie for Fed God [inaudible]
or her sister Frieda from recto fun,
uh,
how the long and very
passionate relationship eventual
marriage bit DH Lawrence
and probably many of you in high school
have red DH Lawrence and sons in lovers
sounds in lovers,
was inspired by Frida phone.
Recto fan was a very durable
and complicated relationship.
Uh, well this is a Vba in Heidelberg, uh,
last time in his life. Um, uh,
the early version labor was mainly
in antiquity in 1903 and four heroes,
the Protestant ethic, then the
big world religions, China,
India and Judaism.
And then finally economy and society.
And on the finished manuscript.
This is the first edition
of the Protestant ethic. Uh,
well I think I probably
skip this one because I've,
you're talking to the Protestant that
later now this is the vapors housing
Heidelberg.
As you can see,
University of Heidelberg Treaty
that professors quite nice.
Um, well, uh,
Marianna was running us alone
in this house, uh, with, uh, uh,
extra ordinary intellectual
circle around them.
This is Mariana Vapor. Um,
uh, she was, as I said,
a wonderful woman. Um, uh, uh,
he was actually kind of second
cousin that his grandfather was a,
the, uh, Max Weber's fodder. Uh, uh,
uh,
she was also a formidable intellectual.
Her book vives and moderates in the
evolution of law was a great success.
Um, Emile Durkheim reviewed
the book and at that time,
Ariana was much more famous
than Max Faber was a Max Stern,
quite nationalistic,
as many other Germans
during the first world war.
But then he's experiences of the
horrors of the first world war.
And partially I think the
relationship as a from Niko Fan,
um, uh, tourance him from
a committed liberal, uh,
who just had nothing else to see,
but approving things about
modernity. Uh, somebody,
we Scott a liberal and in despair,
he remains liberal for his life,
if you will over say that capitalism is
the only viable system we can live in.
Modernity has new alternative,
but he beginning increasingly the,
to show the downside of these modernity.
He said,
I cannot come up with anything better,
but it should not prevent me
to see that this enchantment,
the lost of magic in the modern world
and the horrors of the modern world.
A review you're talking
about this, uh, uh, later on,
uh, he actually nationalism
or had impact on him. Uh,
he actually was a part of the delegation
at the Versailles peace gt and he was
responsible for inserting article
48 into the very Marcos situation,
which unfortunately was used for
Hitler to gain power in 1930 to see,
I mean, that's that waiver camp Shelby,
how they're responsible for Nazis.
And this is something I have
to share with you. Well, uh,
the last work economy and society is
mainly a theory of domination and Vivia of
talking about, uh, next
week while domination is,
he basically combines power,
which has legitimated is
the concept of domination.
And what he does,
he develops a theory,
a fair human history has
subsegment types of domination.
So that major departure for marks,
right?
The social history is not describes
as subset when more so production,
but different types of domination.
Okay.
So that was the life and Varick Max Faber.
And now let's smoke,
turn into,
uh,
the Protestant ethic and try
to do this in 20 minutes,
which we are not be easy.
Okay.
So this is a I city covers from the,
uh,
nervous breakdown.
His first major book is the Protestant
ethic and the spirit of capitalism.
And that's in many ways a major
departure before the nervous breakdown.
A Viber s is an enthusiast
stick pro capitalist,
Stan [inaudible]. Um, uh,
his major concern before 1980,
97 is what blocks to development in the
eastern part of Germany and how those
forces which block the development of
capitalism can be overcome is very much a
liberal in the sense of Adam
Smith and John Stewart, the male.
Then he asks his nervous breakdown and
the person who is a merging looks like a
person who has been
thinking about Nicha right.
Why staring ahead of himself agreed deal.
And that beginning to show already
in the Protestant Ethic Bell,
uh,
he was working at a time when Marx's
was the dominant intellectual force in
Germany. The Social Democratic
Party in Germany was gay,
gaining ground and beginning to do
extremely val after election says vow and
therefore, uh, uh,
in my reading Max v Birth project is to
challenge Marxism in a fundamental ways.
And the Protestant attic is a
first and major step in the,
the action to challenge mark sees me.
So what is the marks?
They bird that bay.
If you are injured us sit in a it
ivy or teach a seminar next semester,
which will only deal with this slide.
What I'm presenting here to tell you
I bought you will be asked Judy the
laughter of text from marks and labor.
Now a historic on maturity.
Allah Islam, right?
Suggest to um, uh, uh, that uh,
uh, uh, it's only economic
forces which explain, uh,
um, uh, history, uh, um, vapor said,
look,
ideas mattered to you.
You cannot deduce ideas and
culture or features from Ecuador.
Me Go on auditions. Um, also, ah,
the virus has no problem. What
motivates human beings, survival,
economic interests.
A vapor said no.
We are not only motivated
by economic interests,
we are also motivated by tradition.
We can be motivated by values.
Uh,
he has a more complex
notion of human not evasion.
Then as I mentioned,
a history cannot be described
as subsequent van of production.
But change is,
is the nature of power.
The different type of motivation
but changes from time to time.
Historically how people
in position of power,
what kind of claims do they make for
you to obey and how you internalize,
right? Uh, the principles
of your subordination.
And he develops these
different types of uh, uh, of,
of authorities,
right.
Made three major types
to additional authority,
charismatic or authority and
booted liberal authority, legal,
rational authority.
This is his son,
but awkward term to
describe the liberal system,
what we would call liberalism.
And finally class,
they uses the term of class,
but he said they are not based,
you should not identify class on property
relationship but on marketplaces and
marks make an error by believing that
class is all of us existed in history
classes or new phenomenon which
emerges only with modern marketing,
integrated cap economies,
mark market economies or right.
What are the major teams
in the Patterson ethic?
It starts with that rather uninteresting.
Bart.
He offers some empirical evidence that
is a correlation between being rich and
being Protestant. Um, uh,
well this is no proof of
causality is a kind of prime,
a fishy evidence of what he does.
I think that's probably the weakest part
of the book. Then he asked a question,
what is the spirit of capitalism?
What is the world view of capitalism?
Then he looks at Lucas conception of
Kalin calling and what it has to do with
the spirit of capitalism.
Then he looks at the religious
foundations of [inaudible],
these worldliest skepticism and how
reformation formation brings these by.
Um, and a in particular
the interpretation of in,
in Calvinism and the teaching
of predestination. Okay.
So these are the crucial issues so of
religious stratification and affiliation
to social stratification. As
I said, this is, uh, uh, uh,
the weaker part of the book.
You really are.
He should do it if you will read the
whole book as a prime, a fishy evidence,
that is something going on here.
Look at the data and it turns
out that Protestant countries,
we're probably ahead of cow cattle,
Catholic countries in capitalism,
and look at the very
[inaudible] people and you've,
you'll see more Protestant
and Catholics. Uh, well,
not a very forceful argument.
He himself is a bit unclear about this
because he does not quite know what
causes what, um, is this, uh, uh, uh, uh,
somehow, um, uh, uh,
people,
uh,
Protestant inherited more valves or
because the apparatus and they can create
more of else. But you know, if you
are looking at American history,
that is certainly a prime, a
fishy evidence for this, right?
I think about 19th century
United States. Uh, right. Uh, uh,
uh, it was wasp wife,
Anglo Saxon and Protestant,
right?
And then they were the poor people coming
in and who they Daver the Irish and
the Italian and what, what does what,
what was the religion? Roman Catholic.
Right. So I think if you are
thinking in 19th century,
late 19th century us, the kind of
empirical evidence is, you know,
pretty persuasive.
But otherwise of course,
I don't think this will
stand up for scrutiny.
But I think this is just to start the
argument now comes to the more serious
one. What is the spirit of
capitalism? And this is a,
that are two important point he need.
He says,
what is unique about spatty the capitalism
that the greed is turned into an
ethical imperative.
And the other one is that captured the
essence of capitalism is rationalism and
calculation. Now, greed,
uh,
turned into an ethical imperative.
Very interesting point
because as we have seen, uh,
Mark's does not offer any explanation why
on earth suddenly the capitalist start
accumulating capital.
Marcus does not have a theory to
explain the motivation of origin.
All accumulation of capital.
He only said or I,
accumulation of capital
is a kind of death, right?
And once you had capital, you don't
have to assume death. But you know,
the original accumulation
comes close to death.
But he does not explain why on earth
people beginning to accumulate capital and
vapor said,
well,
this is interesting because in most
history people like us who are working day
and night and you know, you, you,
you put our little money in four
over on k's or whatever and you know,
tried to put a little money in the
stock market and you know, more.
In most people, in most human history,
they will say, these people are jerks.
You know, why don't they relax now? They
have enough to eat. They should have fun.
And most of you in digital via probably
never have much fun, right? You'll be,
you'll be working day and night to make
more money there. Does it come from,
he said,
this is unique for capitalism.
This is unique for modernity because
greed to become rich became an EFT,
ethical imperative, right? That is the
essence. And He, it has a lot to do.
The rationalization of
modernity and voc is,
we'll have a lot to do with Calvin
asthma and, uh, uh, bad destination.
And Luther's notion of colleague,
uh,
well this is the point what I
shed, right? The pre capital,
this man actually could not understand us,
right?
They had two very dim light because
they needed it in order to survive.
But once they had enough food
to eat and they had shelter,
they were not running after
money on the longer. Right?
This is something which is
unique for modern man. Uh,
yeah.
Capital isn't it?
A system needs this devotion
to the calling to make money,
right? It is for, for us. Uh, um, uh,
an ethical imperative. You know, uh,
well to what extent the destination,
I don't know about if you are very rich,
uvs say bell,
I have to get richer because I'm doing
good by becoming rich because I'm
creating jobs for others. What
a good person I am. Right?
That's why you want to
become rich, to be uh, uh,
to create jobs for others.
Uh,
now calculation,
this is absolutely crucial for vapor.
He said Val capitol is begins with
rational economic calculation,
which did not exist before
capitalists times a bell.
He kind of the parts here from Adam
Smith for whom rational calculation,
but all of us that people
were just not rational,
they burst said now this is a
unique historical phenomenon
that the beginning to
calculate effort and return
against to each other.
And we invented double bookkeeping,
right?
This is what we spend in terms of money
and our energy and this is our return.
This is our, our profit, which appears.
MMM
sure.
Rational economic calculation
is the key of capital is spirit.
So I,
these are the two things that in order
to her car then to make money makes you a
good person, right? Uh,
it's an altruistic act that you
can become rich. And second,
you are a capitalist. If you make rational
bookkeeping, right? If you don't keep,
you know, your income and expenditures,
you are doing something wrong.
You are not the real capitalist,
right? So in order keeping in mind,
you know, you really have to keep your
checks is more balanced, right? You,
all of us have to know how much
you spend and how much you have.
And the rationale is,
Matt,
there's a big tendency for history
that we are becoming increasingly
rationalized. Uh, right?
And he said all the naive
historical materialism assumes
that ideas or originate
and as reflection of economic situation,
he said the spirit of capitalism was
present before the capitalist store.
There you had to invent rationalism and
rational calculation before you could
have capital accumulation
and capitalism as such.
Now here you come.
Luther's conception of
a one very important,
this shoe is, this is
a, this worldly view.
So big change from Medieval
Catholic theology. Um,
a looter coined the term bear rule
in translating the Bible into German.
And the term Beru has multiple meanings.
Uh,
in English I think it is quite
val translated as calling
do not quite because in
German bedroom has the very pedestrian
simple meaning of occupation.
So if you are filling out a questionnaire,
German language questionnaire for
the line occupations stands roof,
but bear roof is also a core
roof is to call in German.
So Barrow Office that you got costs.
You right there,
you got a roof, you got a call,
right? God costs you right?
You are needed. You have to do something
for God. They'd say this is bare truth.
And what is God calling you to,
to perform val in Yurok,
you patient so vile in medieval SKT
sees the essence of life was after life,
right? You were a saint,
then UV draw from your life.
You hardly ate anything.
You become sane because you all what
you eat is an egg a day and you still
survive, right? Um, uh,
this is saint who'd in the
medieval Roman Catholic sense.
Now this is more good.
Any longer.
Realtor said you have to be active
in this life, in your occupation.
That's the annual St Martin.
Can you withdraw yourself from life
and wait for after life, right?
This is the big innovation
of Lutheran theology,
a sort of therefore right for God once
you is the four from your duties in this
world, right. Rather than to be a sane,
not to consume visual, uh,
and so on and so forth.
Uh, okay. Uh, um, uh, now let's move on.
But water is also a traditional
theorist and vapor knows that,
uh,
in fact his emphasis on barrels means
that you have to perform in the job,
but you have in the social
position what you have.
This is not a theory for change.
It is a theory for the reproduction
of the state to school.
And loader actually stood up against the
peasant revolutions in Germany of his
time and sided with
political conservatives.
And Therefore, uh, vapor
suggest that this statute,
it is a non dynamic view of history made
it impossible for Lutheranism to become
the real moving force.
Uh, um, uh, and therefore,
uh, it remained to
traditionalist. You can,
that's why you needed
Calvinism. And by, by Calvinism.
Now,
the big change in modernity,
that magic is being eliminated but
was magic that we have power over God.
They could force God to do
something for us, right? Uh,
there were prescriptions.
What we do, and this,
these were magical means by
which you have magic. You know,
the magician comes rain doesn't come.
Magician does it.
Streaks and Rainville
calm, right? That's magic.
Now in order to rationalize the bird,
you have to get rid of magic.
A divert becomes rationalize.
You understand where the rain is
coming from and you know, you,
there is hardly anything you can
do to make a [inaudible], right?
So, uh, this is, uh, elimination of magic.
And this is what you see in
the Calvinist church. You walk,
you walk into the Calvinist church,
they don't have any pictures of saints.
You know,
it's has a called nastoff rationalism
ride in a Presbyterian church.
Um,
and what is the most important
element of Calvinism is the theory of
predestination. And that's an very
interesting, uh, uh, teaching,
uh, Calvin, uh, assumed, uh, uh,
and this is basically to chat radical it,
to get rid of any notion of magic
that in fact, whether you'll be,
you'll be saved or you perish was
decided upon your verse by God.
There is nothing you can do
about this. Um, uh, so therefore,
uh, you know, uh, in medieval
Roman Catholic churches,
this is what Luther was revolting against,
unfortunately, diverse, some corrupt,
a Roman Catholic priest who said,
you know what?
Give me a little money and if you
give me money, then you, you'll go to,
to heaven rather dental health.
Right?
So w people could buy
their way into, in, in,
into salvation. Now, Calvin said,
no way. You can't do anything. Uh,
not only not giving money to the police,
which was obviously caught up them
the church and about approved.
It was just kind of caught
up practices of individuals.
But he said, there is nothing you can
do in the life because it has been.
But at this feather stand,
the big question is how on earth
these teaching actually can create the
Protestant work ethic,
viable. They work hard.
If it has been decided pre,
uh, decided before us, uh,
uh, that, uh, uh, uh, Viveo
parish or of will be saved.
Now this will come out actually, um, uh,
from uh, uh, the preachings of, uh,
uh, uh, uh, uh, Calvinist
ministers, actual practices,
a pastoral practices. They said
there are, you know, you are, well,
this is a town of puritanism
that was really a pit place,
right of predestination.
New Haven was created by um,
uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, by them you,
you start teaching, then
you'll will save. Well, uh,
are you concerned whether you go to hell
or heaven? You are, aren't you right?
You don't talk to burn or your life. You
want to know whether you want to heaven,
uh, well that is one way to do
it. Work hard. And if you are,
you'll be rewarded. This will be
a sign that God loves you and you,
you'll go to heaven.
So therefore you are working card,
not in order to buy your way into heaven,
but in order to have the sign of God that
you are on the right trajectory or new
vehicle to him. Well,
he said, unfortunately,
this Protestant ethic groover car to save,
um,
Benjamin Franklin, he signed Benjamin
Franklin, right? Uh, you, uh,
uh, are gone, uh, uh, in
modern capitalism, uh,
because now, uh, uh, the
puritans wanted UCR very hard.
Now this is all gone.
Um,
and what was created actually
the art in an iron cage.
This is a femurs rotation.
Again, you have to take it down.
One of the most frequently cited sentences
from vapor modernity created an eye
on stage where we are actually
working because we are, uh, um,
uh, forced to very, very hard.
And the spirit of capitalism today,
I think he was reading a Veblen,
uh, and the theory of the leisure
class and looking at American,
uh,
well seen by the early 20th century
who started to have a good life,
not only to save who Dave
would not follow any longer.
Benjamin Franklin advice. Uh, uh,
get up early when the song rises and
go to bed when the sun SAS because you
don't want to burn the candle and waste
money on the candle when you burn.
Right? Pat was the Reorg, right? Um, uh,
purely turns spirit.
The spirit which created
this very institution,
Yale University,
Right born burn your candle
stride because you raised money,
save money.
That's what we are pleased God.
That's what will be the sign that
you are having saved. Now he said,
this is unfortunately not any longer
because people are actually um,
uh,
ah for consumption.
Good speakers consumption.
Uh,
well and then he ends up, this is a
very important, uh, uh, quotation.
Keep it, um, uh,
and will be helpful for you to understand
the important difference between March
and VBA. He said, look,
but don't misunderstand me.
I don't want to substitute advanced
sided materialist explanation of history,
but Mark's offers with advanced
sided idealist history.
I'm not suggesting that capitalism,
it came out of Calvinism all the time
suggesting that has been an independent
change in theological teaching,
uh,
from Medieval Catholicism
to that formation. Uh,
it was a rationalization.
If religious thinking,
the loss of magic, the rational is
the teaching of the destination.
And if this would not have happened,
capitalist institutions would
not have been able to develop.
Not that they caused that emergence
of capitalist institutions.
There was also an evolution
of the economic systems.
The material change happened in one line,
and the change in the sphere
of ideas happened in another
line. And what he said,
that is an elective
affinity between the two.
If you have the proper ideas and the
proper economic institution goal,
right, then the change happens,
then you have modern capitalism.
If you don't have the right
ideas like Calvinists,
we said like in China,
in the 12 century,
every buzz worthy,
everything was ready for capitalism.
It did not happen because
the con fortune and Tau is,
the ideas at that time did not
give the ideological framing,
which would have helped the
development of capitalism in China.
And that's why China was
hold back, right? Uh,
Calvin Immuno nationalization
of idea could happen,
but if there are no economic
conditions for capitalism,
it will not happen either.
So this is the idea of elective at finity.
He rejects simple cause or relationship
between ideas and material conditions
and he soft stick CQ sit,
we would say today an interactive effect,
right?
That is an interaction between
ideas and material conditions.
He calls it elective affinity.
As such.
Thank you very much.
And the best specialist will be sport
will be posted just before 7:00 PM I have
a discussion section at seven so before
I go to discussion section Thursday,
I've your post the questions.